[Music]
disney and pixar
seoul streaming on disney plus december
25th
music is all i think about
from the moment i wake up in the morning
the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born to play
it's my reason for living
[Music]
oh
hmm this weed the council
is a soul missing
is this heaven no is it h e
double hockey sticks how
coyote no
it's the great before this is where new
souls get their personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth here we are
don't worry you can't crush a soul here
that's what life on earth is for
whoa it's my life
can you help me get back come on
this won't be a disaster that's for sure
you're out there somewhere little song
and i'm gonna find you
life is full of possibilities
you just need to know where to look
[Music]
don't miss out on the joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it disney and pixar's soul
get ready your life is about to start
start streaming december 25th
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies
[Music]
tom and jerry are about to start over
cause that's what
friends are supposed to do
in the big city
[Music]
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings
and we're about to host the wedding of
the century do you think you're
qualified to take on this position i
shine under pressure like a diamond or
rihanna
one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the whatnot
i'll catch it sir
everybody gonna shine
oh wow this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory evolution
if a picture of his mouse is tweeted out
to insta book face or tiki talk
we will be ruined no sir that's not
gonna happen
that rodent is toast
[Music]
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat in a mouth
he's dying with us
i think i might have just pulled this
off really
everybody
in days of yore there were two warriors
i kill for a spicy tuna roll right about
now
get yourself a little something the
brothers grew apart
and a new age began in the middle edge
dad is uncle ted coming for christmas
this year sweetie sometimes you just
grow apart
diamond's all in my ring claire go watch
this gold chain player
that's my girl you can't solve
everything with money but you can't
you haven't changed at all still a big
baby suck it ted you suck get that
out of my face excuse me i hate to
interrupt i mean it's a riveting
conversation but why don't you
suck it
she can talk a lot
i'm in the family business and now you
work for me boomers
baby corp developed a new formula that
can turn a grown-up back into a baby for
48 hours
you want me to be a baby again
[Music]
yep there's the awkward stage ew
baby corporal offer a full memory wipe
following this experience
so what's the crisis an evil genius is
teaching kids
to be very bad bad babies welcome to the
baby to evolution
we're gonna need a disguise to go
undercover now what have you done to me
yeah oh going sailing oh no
[Music]
thanks for always having my back you're
my brother we always stick together
because that's what families
we do to hurry before the formula wears
off
what the [ __ ] aren't you a cutie in that
little karate outfit
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm
sure this isn't something
money can't solve what the fudge
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
clever
give me some shell i gotcha
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
my whole life i trained to become a
guardian of the dragon gem
but this world has changed
[Music]
and its people are divided
now to restore peace i must find
the last dragon
[Applause]
my name is raya
[Music]
you're getting a little too big for this
bud
[Music]
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands it
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is real
and i'm gonna find it what you want when
i do just imagine the lives that could
be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked the legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they can smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon foyer
[Music]
good night
[Music]
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
[Music]
i love my life i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met
[Music]
ready hello little snail what's your
name
scary huh do you want to be friends
me too gary
i'm home gary gare bear
gary gary
[Music]
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends go on dangerous quests
[Music]
hello call me sage good night i'm made
out of sage and i am a sage
so it works out pretty well i'm patrick
my name means
toaster in celtic pretty sure it doesn't
the most amazing places
the lost city of atlantic city boy i
hope we don't lose focus
look i wouldn't worry about us losing
[Music]
patrick that's not an l that's a seven
seven starts with an l
that's weird the spongebob movie
sponge on the run this is gonna be like
a buddy movie oh i love your sense of
irony patrick thank you
i love my sense of ironing too
[Music]
hey where you going i thought we were
going fishing
you're welcome
[Music]
a sequel how original
is anyone hungry yeah starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing
well la deeta i didn't realize i was
with a bunch of sophisticates
families can come in all shapes and
sizes that's why i also feature having
some two-legged children
join them roll it imagine me and our
future children
frolicking this is fun i'm speeding up a
little
i'm speeding up quite a bit
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregors
i swear if it wasn't for me peter just
leave my tomatoes alone you have
everything else honestly my kids will be
so much better behaved go easy on him
as soon as they have a baby we're done
for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on the horizon and
just lock your eyes onto that
[Music]
i love this place what's for lunch
there's a magical place with the ripest
radishes
the sweetest corn it's called the
farmer's market
and if you want an overpriced gift that
will never be used they sell lavender
scented bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy i would never
put you in danger
i promise okay i can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place are you in
are you out
we're in run
no let them go my family's in trouble
and i'm gonna get them back the other
rabbits were taken
and the pig and the hedgehog and the
badger
let's go get the others why are you even
helping me
that's what a dad does
oh no cottontail just discovered sugar
we had a good
run i'm gonna live forever
tell you
[Music]
are you ready this is the main event
he's coming
whoa
come get some of this
who wants a me tentacular
i've got your whole life story tattooed
on my body
yeah in a long history of monster
wrestling there has never been a
champion quite like cynthia
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
the drive the discipline to become the
next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him
did he eat thank you
that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what yeah that's gonna be a hard no for
me
[Music]
oh this is my nightmare
get up here you big lump no one must
know there are dragons in the valley
fire drake stay out of trouble what was
that
human i've always told you they're the
worst what will they do when they find
them
the rim of heaven huh a paradise
for dragons we could go there and lead
everyone to safety how are you planning
to get that
i've got wings haven't i inspired by
cornelia funka's best-selling book
so genius where do we start
hi you're him
yeah climb
[Music]
my pants yes tell
let's get out of here
[Applause]
look at us both roaring
many have searched but no one has found
the rim of heaven who's hungry now's not
the time for depressment
i'm trying to be it was an arranged
marriage
you are much more than you think you are
follow your heart and the truth will
come to you
ready ready join a gang of unlikely
friends
[Music]
yep
dragon rider so we are two next partners
coming soon
[Music]
katie used to be my little buddy go on
nature hikes
skip rocks
are you excited for camp don't make me
go we used to be so connected
hey dad smile you know you could
experience things a whole lot better
without that camera dad this is how i
experience things
yes tomorrow i'm finally leaving for
college but in the meantime i made you
guys this goodbye video you know what
this is our last night together how
about we make
10 seconds family eye contact starting
put your phone down
now no you're allowed to blink it's just
eye contact oh finally no screen's at
the table
linda why are you kicking me i don't
understand i'm just gonna oh look i'll
watch it dad it's too late
look i want to watch it uh
dad this is exactly why i'm excited to
leave tomorrow katie
i know you can fix this
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport i canceled your plane ticket
to college
we are gonna drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family
behold and now i present freaking rick
mitchell and kiss me
dang it katie hey dad can you check the
trunk yeah sure
thank you katie hey kids there's
supposed to be some great eggs around
here this is set down
we hear a pound about to drop our
biggest invention yet
meet the helper bot we promise you they
will
never ever turn even
mom what is that
greetings humans
technology rising up sayonara
robots roaming the streets what is this
strange creature
dog pig dog pig dog loaf of bread
the beaches have always been weird no
time to wash your hands
don't worry i never do that's what makes
us great
that's my girl then we just might be
weird enough
to save the world all right hands in
oh oh
okay dad tonight's the big night
i'm ready to be 100 whoa
just like you pretty loud
step into the light
[Music]
you have until moonrise
[Music]
get away from my butt weirdo wow
you can be cool
put them in the poochie salon
the best wolves don't have the sharpest
laws or the pointiest
yes i'm a boy you can look now oh
whoa sweetheart
[Music]
how's she doing she barely speaks to me
i don't need your sympathy uncle
mustang's got a real mean streak she's
just angry
she was rounded up and taken away from
her family
what's her name i haven't given her a
name
[Music]
i yet you lost your family too
you really are beautiful
that's what i'll call you black beauty
we've gotten closer to that philly in
days than i have in weeks
they say horses pick you
[Music]
the rescues have a time limit you can't
sell me
you're my family you know that right
[Music]
she saved my life you know how can a
horse save a person
[Music]
if i fought for every horse i'd ever
loved
out of 100 of them i don't want 100
horses
i just want one
[Music]
this is eleanor the motherland's
youngest trainee
all she wanted was to be a real fairy
godmother
recite it with me please a glittery gown
turns around upside down
i know that i can do this i'm gonna
prove that people
still need fairy godmothers
i'm looking for mackenzie walsh let's
see what we can find
siri search mackenzie walsh okay
here's what i found who said that is
there a genie in there
don't answer that i'm looking for a sad
little girl named mackenzie walsh that
is me no it can't be you you're
old have you seen yourself security
me again i'm your fairy godmother back
off lady
[Music]
morning oh good you're awake too
is this your true love not anymore life
isn't always a fairy tale i
came all this way to help you find your
heart's desire you know what you need
the makeover what oh what have you done
to my eyebrows
magic my house i know right
you turn my dog into a pig this belt got
away from me
oh it's okay he's just here to help with
the housework
[Music]
i know you want to help her
life isn't as simple as happily ever
after fine after all nine out of ten
fairy tales begin with once upon a time
something amazing happened while she was
drinking wine in her sweatpants
i've been trapped in the fairy tale when
the real world is full of so much more
you're starting to believe in magic
aren't you
[Music]
are you sure i can't make you a ball
gown before i go hey please wait no
please
nice dress is it new don't be mad don't
be mad
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking
no loud music even is shaking on a daily
basis
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
who are you
[Music]
call it fake
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
come reason darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
who'd like to hear some christmas carols
bobstock
last christmas me and bob worked on the
streets
[Music]
happy christmas i thought you could use
some christmas cheer
there's a lot of things i could use
right now getting my gas and hot water
back on
that cat does not look happy to me
can you control your dog i wanted to
chat to you about a couple of concerns
you can't take him away from me
if a guy who works on the street is
being separated from his cat at
christmas
it's got to be done by the book
you've got to help me i'm threatening to
take bob away
because i should anyone who knows the
man and the cat get in touch
you have proved your love a hundred
times over it's not normal for a cat to
be out in the streets james gives bob
the choice
to stay at home or go out with him and
every day
bob goes with him i dreamt of snow back
when i wasn't why is it always about you
james what sounds good
breaking they took everything come on my
way
angels are all around us if we just know
where to look merry christmas
merry christmas
christmas isn't the season it's a
feeling
[Music]
whatever form your family takes
that's what christmas is about
the butterfly
[Music]
what's going on
we need to get out of here hey big bear
team up with me i'll get you out of here
who are you i'm not the toughest in the
forest
[Music]
you help me get the courage through and
i'll take you to find your friends
you and i we can make a super strong
team the forest
is full of danger and traps i've seen
all kinds of danger don't try to fool me
don't take that
can i at least rest here
no
help me get the courage fruit what
courage fruit eat it and you'll become
super brave i'd do anything to protect
bramble
[Music]
when you find the ones you want to
protect you'll know how brave you really
are i'm not
i'm not a coward
they won't let you go so easily now
before you spend a few days playing with
them
this holiday season we're thankful for
the pets whose love got us through the
year
but next year get ready to love
even bigger
[Music]
what does sacrifice mean to you means
being selfless
committed now our tradition here
is unlike any other
we're family
now ray these scholarships are yearly
you perform on the field you perform in
the classroom
and if you don't they take that all away
yes coach
[Music]
you can't be satisfied
there's no guaranteed spot on my team
it's my brother
again baymar
ray earlier this morning i got her into
a 30-day inpatient program
we'll be placing feymar in foster care
can i just have a family member watch me
it's cool
you should be getting back to school
anyway i'll be good
something in me is awakening
uh-huh wait
i'll take them all then they say and
stay praying that i wouldn't make it i
had to bring my little brother to live
with me on campus i should look inside
find a motivation
we build bridges and break limits mom's
going
it's just doing me trying to make a
better way when the day's finished you
don't have to do this on your own
for the future we went in the day and
this
[Music]
why are you helping me uh-huh everyone's
family here
this is where you guys are this is where
you shine my brother and i had it kind
of tough growing up
has given me the opportunity to change
my life
my coaches my teammates
these men are my brothers too history in
the making
you've been waiting for this your whole
[Music]
life
[Music]
you